the Georgia Senate runoff has gone
completely off the rails as Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker has
accused Rafael Warnock of sexual assault
and physical assault
what what is he talking about none of us
know and increasingly the question is
being asked does Walker even have any
idea what he's talking about is this
defamation let's look at the clip this
is you know to say it's gotten ugly is
an understatement I genuinely don't know
whether Walker has any idea what he's
saying but that would not be an excuse
here that would not be an excuse this is
the height of dangerous irresponsibility
Herschel Walker spoke yesterday at some
event he's doing these campaign events
All Over Georgia
and he said you know there was physical
abuse and there was sexual abuse who did
it
it has to be Senator Raphael Warnock now
I'll tell you what this relates to in a
moment
here's the clip he's not what he they
claim to be
some of the best
man said that was a sexual abuse that
was physical abuse I'm like who did that
it had to be Senator Raphael Warner
because he was responsible for it y'all
didn't hear about that did you he don't
want to talk about those things because
he don't want you to know that he think
you're going to be he gives a good
senator for you I'm telling you right
now it is time for a change yeah now
if you can make heads or tails out of
that unintelligible word salad
by all means go ahead and do it
this is so difficult because Walker
clearly is saying
that Raphael Warnock sexually abused and
physically abused a kid okay it's clear
that he's saying those words but at the
same time
it's never really clear that Walker has
any idea what he's saying and I know
every time we talk about this oh David
well that's not really issues oriented
or he has a brain injury from football
that hasn't been said or this is because
of his dissociative identity disorder
that he says these things that that's
not the explanation that they're giving
we have to go by what he is saying
and there's a real question as to
whether this is potentially defamatory
now again it's not clear Walker knows
what he's saying because it's never
clear he knows what he's saying but what
this is about relates to allegations
that camp counselors
20 years ago at a camp where Warnock
um uh Warnock ran the camp but there's
no allegations that Warnock did any of
this stuff the allegation is that a 12
year old boy
was forced to sleep outside at the camp
and had urine tossed on him by Camp
counselors okay
absolutely horrible allegations and the
incident was investigated in 2001-2002
it resulted in no charges law
enforcement later called it a
miscommunication and it was never even
alleged that Warnock did any of this
stuff now you could say well if indeed
it happened maybe Raphael Warnock who
was running the camp had some ultimate
responsibility but but the idea that
Warnock is a sexual or physical abuser
is completely out of this world now the
question then becomes is this defamatory
uh because in general you know if some
random person on Twitter with five
followers tweets that Raphael Warnock
sexually and physically abused someone
it's not defamatory uh because it's not
damaging to Warnock but when we look at
the requirements for defamation the uh
information that is allegedly defamatory
must be published well that means that
it's public and here's the video we
looked at the video so it certainly
meets that standard the person being
defamed was clearly identified by the
statement meaning is it clear that
Walker is talking about his opponent
Senator Rafael Warnock I would argue
it's clear that it is he says Raphael
Warnock is the one who did this there's
no confusion as to whether he means
someone else by that name or anything
like that number three the remarks have
a negative effect on the person's
reputation that's the question
we don't know yet but if it starts to
spread in such a tight race
the completely baseless allegation that
Warnock is a physical and sexual abuser
you could argue that those remarks have
a negative impact on warnock's
reputation
number four is is the information
demonstrably false well it's hard to
prove negatives but there's certainly no
evidence that these allegations about
Warnock are true and the police
investigation generally into this
incident at the camp which isn't even
alleged to be warnox doing
found no legal wrongdoing and it didn't
even allege that Warnock was the one
doing it and then number five the
defendant is at fault in other words
that it is indeed Herschel Walker who um
uh made made these claims and made them
uh in a way that is consistent with with
uh um Reckless disregard or there's
different different standards in
different states you arguably have a
defamation case here now what I care
more about is can we just get Raphael
Warnock over the finish line
before some new thing comes up that gets
in the way of this campaign and I think
again without defending or attacking the
individual incident and what supposedly
happened to this 12 year old what Walker
said is not even remotely based in fact
then the crowd just sort of goes along
with it the real disturbing part of all
of this is that this race even went to a
runoff that's really the disturbing part
that the Georgia voters Georgia
Republican voters and this is a theme
that we are following in their
desperation to not vote for a Democrat
they are voting for someone who is
completely unqualified doesn't have a
sensible position that he can articulate
on any issue and on a personal level is
a complete hypocrite with regard to the
policy positions that he sort of claims
to Advocate to the extent that we can
understand him uh completely against
abortion in all cases no exception well
he urged two women and paid for two
women to get abortions
um it says we we need we need men not to
be absent fathers he's an absent father
to multiple kids that we know about it's
not even totally clear to me how many
kids it is and on and on and on that
alone is not a reason to vote against
him but the totality of the situation
should lead to this guy losing by 40
points and instead it was so close
within one point with neither candidate
able to secure fifty percent of the vote
that now we have a runoff on December
6th let's really hope that our Georgia
friends who vote in Georgia get out
there and make this extraordinarily
important vote we'll have live coverage
on December 6th that's the day of the
runoff going now from Georgia to Arizona
Kerry Lake who lost she lost nothing
happened other than Kerry Lake lost her
opponent Katie Hobbs got more votes in
the Arizona gubernatorial election on
November 8th Kerry Lake was recently at
Trump's house in Mar-A-Lago and now all
of a sudden she says she's going to try
to overturn the election results you
know we I don't know that I can say that
we were joking around but we certainly
talked about how it seems very clear
that the new strategy and it's not even
really a strategy because it hasn't
worked at all it's it's more of like a
last-ditch effort tactic the new thing
we're going to see from these
Republicans is when they lose they will
say that it's rigged and then they will
try to overturn the election and they
will continue putting out these
imaginary Milestones oh well we're
getting very close to submitting
affidavits all right I mean affidavits
aren't evidence strictly speaking they
can be considered but affidavits are not
evidence of wrongdoing will very soon a
court is going to hear our case Mike
pillow's been talking about that for two
years we're moving for decertification
we heard that one from Steve Bannon many
times is there such a process as
decertification no but we're moving
towards decertification and by the way
keep donating keep donating to me donate
to Trump donate to everybody okay so
here's a clip of Carrie Lake Carrie Lake
lost she had this pompous arrogance
going into the election I will be the
next governor of Arizona more people
voted for her opponent
when things go right the person who gets
more votes wins Carrie Lake doesn't like
that it looked like she was getting
ready to move on now she says she's
assembling evidence and she's going to
run some kind of campaign to overturn
the election Sarah to remedy this
assault on our democracy
this isn't about Republicans Or
democrats this is about our sacred right
to vote yeah what's funny is as much as
they claim it's not about Republicans Or
democrats they only claim that this
fraudulent stuff took place when a
Democrat has defeated a Republican
that so so find me a case where you try
to overturn an election in which a
republican defeated a Democrat find me
one example
a right that many voters were sadly
deprived of on November 8th
tens of thousands of you have reached
out pleading with me to fight this fight
is that even true tens of thousands I'm
sure thousands but tens of thousands
reached out just assured I will because
if we give up now we will no longer have
a country
attorneys are working diligently to
gather information sure whistleblowers
are coming forward and the curtain is
being lifted
whether done accidentally or
intentionally it is clear that this
election was a debacle that destroyed
any trust in our elections what she
means is I lost arizonans who choose to
make their voice heard on Election Day
should not be disenfranchised or
punished for choosing to vote in person
now what she's referring to is that for
a little while a few tabulators in
Maricopa County didn't work
that that's what she's talking about
yet they were
I want you to know Arizona I will
continue fighting until we restore
confidence and faith in our elections
you know I'm pretty confident and and I
have faith in what happened the
candidate who got more votes Katie Hobbs
is going to be the next governor of
Arizona and all of the evidence points
to the voters of Arizona wanted Katie
Hobbs to be the governor they can
recount it over and over they can do
these Audits and remember
they call for an audit the audit is done
and then they go no that was the wrong
type of audit they only looked
at a recount of the ballots without
evaluating whether the ballots were
valid the ballots were valid
it's the wrong type of audit well you
know they didn't look at whether there
were barbecue sauce stains from a type
of barbecue sauce common in Missouri you
shouldn't have Missouri barbecue sauce
on Arizona ballots it just doesn't make
sense clearly there was some kind of
fraud what about bamboo fibers what
about uh pictures of koala bears tucked
into the ballots it's all very you will
never satisfy them
that the process has been completed the
way they want and Luke Beasley our
correspondent who was recently at a
trump Rally For Us in uh
I believe he went to the Pennsylvania
one if they blend together I believe he
was in Latrobe Pennsylvania
Luke or was it North Carolina doesn't
matter Luke interviewed folks where they
said oh there was all this fraud and
Luke said yeah but there's no actual
evidence and they did the audit they go
no no no no that wasn't really an audit
in the way we wanted and what they mean
is it wasn't an audit that overturned
the election so that the Republican won
it's so completely predictable
thankfully it's over I mean it Katie
Hobbs won
she will be the governor nothing's
getting overturned period and the
problem now becomes this is standard
operating procedure for Republicans they
have now adopted this we don't like the
results we say it was rigged we say it's
just not believable that Katie Hobbs won
because she has fewer Facebook followers
it's similar to it's not believable
Biden won because his live streams
didn't get a lot of viewers or his
rallies didn't have huge crowds this is
the new refrain this is the new refrain
and unfortunately you know after 2020 we
wondered is this ending with 2020 no it
extended to the special elections in
2021 in January in Georgia it extended
to the midterm elections a couple weeks
ago in 2022 and it seems pretty clear
that this is going to be the narrative
that continues if we lost it was rigged
with all of the exact same statements
it's extraordinarily dangerous and so
far it hasn't flipped any races for them
imagine for a second that this story
about fraud and lawsuits and recounts
and barbecue sauce on ballots and all
this stuff imagine it actually flips an
election for them at some point
they will never stop using it if that's
the case that's why it's really
important that we ensure they aren't
actually able to steal an election by
claiming fraud and using these tactics
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David packman show is an audience
supported program we depend on you to do
what we do we exist to the extent that
people want us to exist and allow us to
exist and you can sign up for a
membership at joinpakman.com it's really
cheap we do an extra show every single
day for our members it's a bonus show
where you want to make money yeah
everybody else
themselves is bad yeah it's called the
bonus show as Alex Jones has
acknowledged we also do a commercial
free audio and video stream every single
day we do members only town halls and I
would love for you to sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get a sizable
discount William Barr now says there is
a basis to indict Donald Trump
but maybe I'll still vote for him in
2024. this is really beyond belief and
it's
it's not beyond belief in the sense that
these Republicans former Trump
Associates and staffers who we say hey
you know what
he or she they saw the light eventually
John Bolton eventually came out and said
Trump's incompetent and dangerous
whoever the case may be at the end of
the day they are still part of the no
matter how bad Trump is I'm not voting
for a Democrat so let's go through this
this is truly stunning stuff this was an
interview on PBS PBS where Bill Barr was
interviewed by Margaret Hoover and he
believes first and foremost that the
Department of Justice at this point
almost certainly has a legitimate legal
basis for indicting Donald Trump first
clip take a listen in September you said
the justice department was getting close
you said quote getting close to having
enough evidence to indict Trump in the
classified documents investigation but
you also said you hope they don't indict
him
in your view is there ever a
circumstance where you think is
appropriate to indict a former president
oh yes
um
you know if a former president commits a
crime you know especially a serious
crime they should be indicted for it if
the Department of Justice can show that
these were indeed very sensitive
documents which I think they probably
were and also show that the president
consciously was involved in misleading
the department deceiving the government
and playing games after he had received
the subpoena for the documents
that's those are serious that's serious
that's a serious one I said I I
personally think that they probably have
the basis for legitimately indicting the
Press I don't know I'm speculating but
but given what's gone on I think they
probably have the evidence that would
check the box they have the case
that's pretty clear that's a former
Attorney General saying they probably
have the evidence to legitimately indict
my former boss the former president so
certainly William Barr would not
consider voting in 2024
for a guy who so mismanaged and
mishandled at least some aspects of his
job that his behavior was worthy of an
indictment right I mean William Barr is
a man of the law and of Law and Order
former Attorney General lawyer he would
not say and by the way I'm in a vote to
re-elect that guy who I think we can
legitimately indict
well he might he might vote for him if
Donald Trump were the nominee of the
Republican party again would you support
him
well I'm just hoping it never comes to
that because I think it would be a
tragedy if he's our nominee if he's the
Republican nominee
um could you vote against him could you
vote not for the Republican if Donald
Trump or the Republican again I think it
gets down to what I said which is I
would have to make the Judgment at that
point
the impact on the country and I'll have
to see what's going on in the world what
who the Democratic nominee is if it's a
progressive Democratic nominee I can't
imagine voting but right between a
criminal president
and a progressive I'm not voting for the
progressive I'm clearly voting for the
criminal illogically Progressive versus
somebody who orchestrated an attack on
the capitol who betrayed as oath to the
Constitution as you said in your words
you still might vote for him
yeah yeah I move over sure betrayed as
though sure but at least he doesn't want
Universal Health Care for everybody I
mean that's crazy depending on all this
it's hard for me to project what the
future holds the question is always a
comparative one you have to have made a
choice between two people I don't
believe in Throwing Myself Away on a
third party you don't rule out
supporting president Trump again no I
don't
depends on the circumstances what I pray
that that doesn't come yeah
I think the reason our Republic is in
Jeopardy is because we are not throwing
up the best and the brightest for these
offices that's for damn sure that's for
damn sure so a reminder when we stumble
across so-called sensible Republicans
who have figured out the truth about
Trump and
at the end of the day it's about
self-preservation it's about what's good
for me now I think there are some
exceptions when I look at Mitt Romney
I'm not a fan of Romney but he did have
this brief moment where it seemed like
he was sort of auditioning to be
Secretary of State he went and had
turtle soup and Frog's legs or whatever
it was with Trump uh before Trump was
inaugurated
and it didn't work out that way and
maybe it would have gone differently and
I'd feel differently but Mitt Romney has
pretty consistently stuck to his
framework for conservatism as he sees it
and it has not really overlapped with
trumpism he's been clear he marked
marched with the black lives matter
protesters he has been consistently
anti-trump he entertained it when he met
with Trump that time I it's closer to
a type of Republican I can respect not
in terms of agreeing with their
positions but in terms of how they've
handled all this but the the Bolton the
you know even Liz Cheney to some degree
I I just don't know I just don't know I
think this is basically what we should
expect from all of them and Barr says
listen betraying your country and all of
that
better than an ideological Progressive
which tells you a lot of what you need
to know about the Maga crowd a Donald
Trump is absolutely Furious that
Republicans are telling him stay the
hell away from Georgia there is a senate
runoff in Georgia of critical importance
on December 6th it is Raphael Warnock
the incumbent Democrat against
Republican Challenger Herschel Walker
the winner on December 6th will
determine do Democrats hold the Senate
50-50 needing com needing every
Democratic vote and then Kamala Harris
as a tiebreaker to get things done or
you Democrats take a 5149 uh Helm of the
Senate making either Joe manchin or
Kirsten Cinema a little bit Irrelevant
in getting things passed it's very
important there is of course this guy
named Donald Trump who's running for
president in 2024 he wants to be seen as
the Savior and the winner everywhere
despite his pretty bad endorsement
outcomes in the November 8th 2022
midterms and Republicans seem to
recognize if Trump comes to Georgia to
quote help Walker it might actually be a
really bad thing and there's a very
interesting uh Rolling Stone article
Trump is pissed Republicans keep telling
him to stay away from Georgia it's by
Aza wind subsang and Nikki Ramirez with
a runoff election looming they write the
newly announced 2024 candidate doesn't
want his Rivals getting any attention
while his party Wards him away
and they write as Republicans poor party
resources into the Georgia Senate runoff
Donald Trump is getting irritated at the
idea that virtually no one of importance
wants him to campaign in Georgia in the
lead-up several Republicans and Trump
allies already told him not to hold the
Georgia rally ahead of the runoff
according to two people familiar with
the matter
Trump has however suggested that those
close to those close to him that he'll
react poorly if Florida's governor Ron
DeSantis campaigns in Georgia while the
Republican Party holds its once
Undisputed leader at arm's length people
who have recently spoken to Trump fear
if DeSantis announces a Georgia event it
would guarantee that Trump also heads to
the state Trump has also vehemently
argued to AIDS and confidence that his
presence in the runoff would be a net
positive for Walker and he's accused
pundits and Republicans who say he
shouldn't go to Georgia are
unintelligent Trump haters I want Trump
in Georgia I really do hold rallies talk
about how the next election is going to
be rigged and how the previous one was
rigged and it was stolen and it was all
stolen stand right next to Herschel
Walker and say this is one of the people
we need to get in there but it was
rigged and how where's my
African-American and all the crazy stuff
do it I think it will be bad for
Herschel Walker if Walker wins there is
obviously something very wrong with the
people of Georgia
and the fact that Warnock didn't win
outright and we need a runoff I've
already said complete and total disaster
I'm no no question whatsoever
we are where we are right now which is
that the 2.1 percent of the vote that
went to the Third Party candidate could
go either way and it's going to come
down to turnout and it's going to come
down to ground game I can think of few
things worse for Walker
than what was bad for other candidates a
few weeks ago which is Trump showing up
ranting for 90 minutes or two hours
about voter fraud and how he did really
well in 2020 and then kind of saying
yeah and vote for this guy or gal
it wasn't good for the contested races
it wasn't good for mastriano it wasn't
good for Oz it wasn't good for Tudor
Dixon it wasn't good for Kerry Lake J.R
Majewski lost John Gibbs lost and on and
on and on so I say bring Trump to
Georgia and let him wreak havoc even
better would be if it becomes for lack
of a better term
a penis size contest between Trump and
DeSantis to the detriment of Herschel
Walker we know that Barack Obama will be
campaigning with Rafael Warnock if the
scheduling lines up we will cover that
live and if indeed this sort of slurry
of uh Republican rallies with Trump
DeSantis Etc materialize for Walker we
will cover those as well but most
importantly and I know I've said it
before and I'm going to say it again
most importantly
if you live in Georgia
if you're registered to vote in Georgia
make sure that you vote because this one
is of critical importance make sure also
that you're subscribed to our YouTube
channel if you're watching right now on
YouTube and you look at that subscribe
button up there or down below wherever
it is
and it's enabled if it says subscribe
rather than subscribed hit that button
there's over three million people who
watch our videos and don't yet subscribe
help us get to 2 million subscribers
we're gonna take a quick break and be
right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to Welcome to the program today Scott
Galloway who's professor of marketing at
nyu's Stern School of Business and also
author of adrift America in 100 charts
uh Scott great to have you on I really
appreciate it
uh thanks for having me David you know
there's always a risk to introducing
anyone because my audience will say well
David you're you're really very wrong
about how you framed this guest but one
of the things that well I'm going to
acknowledge that risk and say one of the
things I find interesting about uh some
of your work is you talk about uh men
and gender and masculinity in a way that
to me seems quite both empathetic but
also realistic when it comes to
um men and boys without falling into
what some might describe as a sort of
like a men's rights activist type
umbrella and dismiss what you say I've
actually been really interested about a
lot of the things that you've talked
about about modern masculinity do you
find that there is a desire from those
who listen to your commentary on gender
and Men there's a desire to put you
either on this side or that side or that
there really is a sort of welcoming the
the way you want to discuss it which I
think is much more nuanced than many
others
all right thanks for the question it's a
thoughtful question it's changed a lot
if you talked about if you advocated for
young men
two years ago and said that you know
when it was 60 40
male female in college and now it's
reversed but we're not talking about it
people saw it as a zero-sum game and
they immediately conflated advocating
for young men or highlighting some of
the struggles young men face as being
misogynist you couldn't be Pro male
without being anti-female
and over the last 24 months has changed
and unfortunately I think some of that
is because a lot of the a lot of the
kind of pro there was a lot of thinly
veiled misogyny masking is pro mail I
don't I think some of the celebrities
that are or people on Tick Tock that
have gotten some attention it's just
blatantly a fairly conservative
um there's some there's some troubling
aspects to to some of the people who've
been labeled as Pro mail and that is
they're blaming women or that the
similar content does come off as
misogynist so I don't think that's
helped have a serious conversation but
you have people like Richard Reeves and
talking his great book of Boys to Men
I've read about him so far cap said look
this is clearly an issue and the the
group I hear from I hear from three
cohorts I hear from young men and
oftentimes they're upset because they
think I'm accusing them of being in
cells and so I get both positive and
negative feedback from young men I get
some negative feedback from young women
who feel as if look where where were you
men have had a 400 year Head Start where
were you when women were struggling and
I would argue well I think we were there
for women and we still have work to do
but I think Society has been there
um the people I get the most support
from hands down are mothers and the
conversation goes something like this I
have two daughters one's a pen one's in
PR in Chicago both killing it and I have
a son who's in the basement vaping and
playing video games and the data is just
overwhelming and we're finally having an
honest conversation about the fact that
three times as likely to be addicted
four times as likely to kill themselves
12 times as likely to be incarcerated uh
two for every one male college graduate
in the next year uh five years we're
gonna have two female college graduates
so there are real issues here and also
there's an emerging Class A recognition
that the people who would like more
economically and emotionally viable
young men is women
so I I think we're finally having what
I'd call a civil conversation around it
one of the things that I find really
interesting and I hope I'm summarizing
some of the things you've written and
said accurately and if not I'm sure
you'll tell me is that you point out or
I at least interpret some of the things
you say is pointing out that some of the
Grievances that may be the more
right-leaning folks on this issue have
about the state of young men
are a direct result of some of the
cultural shifts and norms and stories
that are told by those very people in
terms of I'll give a few examples
um what is what is masculine when it
comes to Parenting as an example and
these images of and stereotypes of hey
you know the the dad pushing around the
stroller rather than working that's not
masculine in the way that it should be
for as an example or that's my example
not yours necessarily or stories about
you know empathy and being in touch with
one's emotions should be uh should not
be welcomed for example among so-called
masculine men it seems to mean I'm
curious whether you agree that some of
those stories maybe perpetuate the very
problems that you're pointing out
yeah it's an interesting conversation
because I think masculinity is a
wonderful thing and it's been
incorrectly conflated with toxicity
which is just [ __ ] toxic masculinity
is a term that has really been
destructive because there are just
certain situations where people want to
demonstrate masculinity and the key is
to Define what it means I think it means
being more risk aggressive it means
Taking Chances
if I tried to distill a modern or a
mature form of masculinity down to a
statement it would be acquiring skills
and strengths such that you can protect
and advocate for others and by the way
masculinity is not the sole domain of
people born as men I think a lot of
women demonstrate masculinity I think a
lot of men demonstrate wonderful
feminine attributes I'm kind of most of
my friends I would describe as as having
more feminine attributes than the
majority of men but let's celebrate
femininity in the wonderful things it
brings to the fore and also masculinity
so I believe for example and I've gotten
for saying this I think every man should
take economic responsibility for their
household and by the way sometimes that
means recognizing as much as it may hurt
that your partner is better at that
whole money thing than you and taking
more responsibility for supporting her
career his career and getting out of the
way I think that's a masculine attribute
somebody and ideally both of you need to
take economic responsibility for the
household I think being really really
strong
in having incredible grit and resilience
lifting heavyweights running long
distances in your mind and in the gym is
a wonderful thing men are stronger than
women lean into that they're stronger
physically women are stronger in terms
of their ability to endure you know they
have much higher threshold for pain
otherwise they would never survive
childbirth yeah but I say to young men
if you are not strong you should be able
to walk in any room and have the
confidence that if she's not real you
could kill and eat everybody or outrun
them and I'm not suggesting you do
either of those things but I'm
suggesting it's a wonderful thing to
lean into and there's nothing wrong with
it and then what do you do with that
strength you're more confident you're
more kind in certain situations you
de-escalate the situation the strongest
most impressive men I've ever met in a
bar fight are the ones that step in and
de-escalate the situation that's what it
means to be a man that's what it means
to do to express masculinity so I like
the idea of trying to Define you know if
you're Tarzan what Vines you're going to
swing on masculinity for me when I was
you know you look like a very young man
David but when I was young I thought
masculinity meant being awesome sleeping
with as many strange women as possible
and being ripped I didn't go into the
gym to get fit I went in to be big and
now as I've gotten older I find that you
know being Civic voting being friendly
to your neighbors taking an interest in
a child that isn't yours I think that
being really strong you know now for my
age and I hate to say that I have to
qualify everything for my age those
things make me feel strong like ball and
I'm leaning into those things I love
those things I love making and spending
a lot of money I love protecting people
and I'm doing a lot of virtue signaling
right now but those are masculine
attributes I'm I'm a risk aggressive
person I've started businesses and
there's nothing and I'm physical on a
lot of dimensions and those are
wonderful attributes and by the way
women can demonstrate those attributes
but masculinity should be absolutely
celebrated when ukrainians or when
Russians pour over the Border
as Bill Maher said you know the
Ukrainian Army you want some of that big
energy and I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I think we need
to celebrate it it comes with downsides
it comes with upsides as does every
other attribute of the species
but um I I'd say lean into it and just
Define what it means and we need a more
mature
version of masculinity last thing I want
to mention on this and then I want to
talk about the book a little bit I'm
curious I I've not heard you comment on
this and I don't know if you have one of
the things I've observed over the last
six to 18 months in the political space
has been that one of the topics that
gets the biggest rise out of right-wing
crowds and by this I'm talking about
your typical Trump rally as well as CPAC
in Texas over the summer what got the
crowd the most excited was stuff about
gender and trans people the one of the
biggest Applause lines at CPAC over the
summer was when Ted Cruz said my
pronouns are kiss my ass and the crowd
went absolutely crazy one of the biggest
Applause lines during the Trump rally is
when Trump talks about
a trans woman in a weightlifting
competition easily lifting hundreds of
pounds more than everybody else and just
how you know we got we got to get men
out of women's sports Etc Etc do you
make anything or what do you make of the
fact that those stories have become so
titillating to a large portion of the
country
well when when everything isn't you know
when everything is a nail you know all
you have or is what looks like a
cultural war and that is we don't want
to talk about income inequality we don't
want to talk about inflation or growing
the economy so let's get people
emotionally triggered by a small number
of
uh instances the the governor of South
Dakota spends precious resources and
time trying to pass a law that protects
women's sports from transgender athletes
and by the way conceptually it's a
conversation worth having I don't think
a six foot five person born as a male
who's had testosterone pour over their
muscle and bone structure should be
competing in what had traditionally been
a woman's swimming I think that's an
honest conversation we should have but
when you have the governor of a state
passing laws the quote unquote protect
girls Sports and then we find there
isn't a single instance in the entire
state
of a of a person who has tried to be
compete as a woman who was born a male
you have to say well are are they are
they interested in an honest
conversation or are they just interested
in triggering people and and leading a
astounded path
of demonstrating hate towards a
community that has been subject to just
so much [ __ ] it's just I mean at the
end of the day the far right claims to
embrace Jesus we're supposed to be
loving people we're supposed to be
accepting of them we're supposed to be
and they also one of the things I love
about GOP principles is in really tough
issues you defer to the individual why
wouldn't we let families and doctors
figure out what is or isn't the right
thing about this if we end up in a
Statewide swim meet okay let's have a
conversation but we're talking about
it's again it's it's a similar
conversation where they say well
Democrats want you to be able to abort
your baby you know the week before you
your water breaks that doesn't happen
it's a theoretical situation meant to
trigger people emotionally in divide us
it's not productive it's rooted in hate
it's rooted in cheap politics and it it
it doesn't Advance us forward one of the
things from my book is a segue to the
book looking at all the issues of plague
us David whether it's income inequality
whether it's the very serious issues
around climate change whether it's you
know our polarization if America's
problems are a horror movie it would be
the cause coming from inside of the
house
instead of taking time to focus on how
we
establish more chips to ensure that
we're not relying on the Chinese during
a conflict instead of focusing on how we
ensure that we bring up our bottom fifth
of education level that we get one out
of five households out of poverty that
have children we start talking about
this [ __ ] and we start talking and
when I say [ __ ] I mean anything that
divides US 34 percent of Democrats I'm
sorry 54 percent of Democrats are
worried the kid's going to marry a
republican a third of people in each
party being people in the other party
are their mortal enemy Americans will
never have greater allies than other
Americans and I find the far right
especially but also the far left are
more interested in embarrassing the
other side than they are about advancing
the nation and we have to get back to a
point where we recognize first and
foremost we're Americans we're not
Republicans Democrats I'm a huge World
War II history buff I have this great
photo of these men Wade into the water
as the front gate slammed down on their
landing craft heading towards Omaha
Beach in the invasion of Normandy two
out of three of these men average age 26
wouldn't leave the beach alive and I
imagine that they can suspend the time
space continuum see our problems and go
you can't fix that I can't imagine any
of those men looked at each other and
even knew who was a Republican or a
Democrat so we are energy independent we
are food independent we have eradicated
diseases we are more we are more
prosperous than any nation in the world
but we've decided we don't like each
other and when you take very tiny
examples of Trans athletes that are
meant to evoke an emotional response all
you are doing is saying I want Americans
to hate each other I don't want America
to move forward I want Americans to hate
each other we should have an honest
conversation parents who want to have an
honest conversation around gender
affirmation and be informed when a kid
under the age of 18
asks for hormone therapy at a school
that's an honest conversation we should
have that conversation but according to
Republican principles we should have it
at the school and the family level and
there are to be blunt this is really an
edge of edge case and they want to turn
it into a cultural issue because they
don't want to really talk about what
ails us so it's like come on let's get
back to where we were as Americans have
more respect for the individual and stop
using edge cases to trigger people such
that we're angry at each other it's
totally unproductive let's talk a little
bit about uh the the book again the book
is adrift America and 100 charts one of
the things that will often happen when
you talk to folks who are maybe to some
degree siled in a particular area is
there's this sometimes instinct to say
here's really the chart or the statistic
or the issue that explains all or the
vast majority of what's going on there's
this desire to be like this is the thing
really that that this is all about
and sometimes it's income inequality or
it's the climate or it's the gender pay
Gap or whatever the case may be one of
the interesting things about your book
is that you actually look at a ton of
different dimensions but I guess the
question I have is is there some
overarching
thing that you believe links these
together in terms of explaining this
adrift status quo that you point out
some some general takeaway which then we
can use to look at some of the specifics
so if you had to zero in on one Shard
that would be Ground Zero
um for the for the detonation and all
our other problems are kind of the blast
zone as you go to different outer Rings
yes it's in the early 70s up until the
early 70s productivity and wage growth
were like two snakes intertwined the
nation got more productive through
manufacturing or processes or service
Technologies and wages went up we got
much more productive we just went up a
lot we shared in our prosperity
in the early 70s wages went flat for 50
years despite the fact that productivity
kept going up and to the right and the
Delta between these two lines is
literally tens of trillions of dollars
in Surplus value that wage earners
current income
didn't get to participate in and I think
that when when you have now for the
first time in the nation's history a 30
year old man or woman isn't doing as
well as his or her parents were at the
age of 30. when you have for the first
time more than half of people under the
age of 30 are not living over the
Romantic partner or a friend they're
living with their parents you have rage
you have shame you have roommates
reminding you of your failure every day
named mom and dad and when people aren't
doing well when the ultimate compact in
our society and that is your kids will
do better than you has been broken
people look for scapegoats they get
angry they start be leaving in a
conspiracy theory they start looking for
Heroes and cult figures that will rally
them and blame somebody else and tell
them that they're victims so the lack of
shared progress we've been enormously
prosperous over the last 50 years we
will produce this month we will we will
produce more output this month and we
produce an entire year in the 1950s it's
our you could see in five to ten years
we might be able to produce as much in a
quarter order is we produce in a decade
in the middle of the last century the
problem is a lot of that Prosperity is
not translating to progress because if
you don't feed the engine that fights
your Wars pays the majority of your
taxes and is responsible for civility
and progress in our nation see above the
middle class a society declines China
has brought 500 million people into the
middle class in the last 50 years we've
shed 10 million so in some ground zero
the epicenter is when wages decoupled
from productivity and does that I mean I
can speculate about how that would
connect to
education that would connect to dealing
with climate issues that would connect
to Social Services access to health care
I mean it seems as though when you think
about that particular chart where you
start to see a separation between
productivity and wage growth you really
can connect that to so many of the
different charts and things you talk
about
yeah it really it just ripples out and
what you have is
um there's this there's a few myths that
we need to bust the first is that the
middle class is a naturally occurring
economic Force it's not if you let the
economy just run totally you know Iron
Rand is totally free market the middle
class starts to erode because wealthy
people get access to powerful
politicians especially with citizens
united who tend to take the tax code
from 400 pages to 4 000 who can navigate
a complex tax code the wealthy if you
can navigate By Starlight you want to
you want to run boat races at night
where run our tax code is complex
people at my income level can afford
people to help them navigate and we end
up with a regressive tax structure
education me and my colleagues every
morning wake up in the morning and say
ask ourselves one question how do we
reduce our accountability while
increasing our compensation we have
found the ultimate strategy and that is
to tap into the 10 wealthiest American
households with a luxury positioning and
that is artificially constrained Supply
such that
30 20 10 admission rates and we stand up
and applaud the dean and the alumni love
it and we've morphed towards this
[ __ ] rejectionist luxury positioning
in our society where once I have a
degree from a good University I want
them to pull up the drawbridge because
then my degree becomes more valuable
once I have a house I show up to the
local review board and try and squash
any new development to make my the price
of my house go up and once I have a
successful tech company I weaponize the
government to not let any emerging
companies come out of the crib through
Monopoly abuse if we don't consistently
create opportunities for other people to
enjoy the prosperity to my generation as
enjoined if you don't have TR if you
don't have churn if you don't stop these
ridiculous bailouts of small businesses
and create a cartoon the wealthiest
people in America are small business
people when you just
bail out rich people and companies
you're robbing from young people because
the reason I'm wealthy is because as I
was coming into my Prime income million
years in 2008 Amazon and apple went down
90 and I got to buy them and then
register a 20 and 40 fold respectively
increase and two years ago we decided to
bail out the markets and as a result as
a result young people didn't get their
shot to buy Brooklyn real estate or
Amazon stock you know at 40 60 70
percent off so America used to be the
best place to get rich it slowly but
surely become the best place to stay
Rich everything we do right now fiscally
and legislatively is an attempt to take
money from a younger generation who have
seen their wealth from go from 19 of GDP
to nine percent we have cut the wealth
of people your age in half the average
person seven-year-old is 72 percent
wealthier than they were 40 years ago
the person average person under the age
of 40 is 22 percent less wealthy My
Generation has basically said to a
younger generation [ __ ] you I got mine
get yours I'm going to borrow your
credit card and your kids credit card
such that Nana and pop-op can upgrade
from Carnival to Crystal Cruises unless
we reinvest in the middle class it will
correct and the means of Correction will
either be War famine or revolution
uh I I hate to end on such a Negative
salad wasn't it not every not every
interview has a happy ending which is
okay which is okay uh we've been
speaking with Scott Galloway professor
of marketing at NYU also author of
adrift America in 100 charts Scott I
really appreciate your time and talking
to me today
David thanks for your good work and
thanks for having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
I apologize in advance but this is going
to be like a little bit of a rant
segment I'm really sick of a particular
type of message that I received a few of
recently about Elon Musk and Tesla and
it's the you must be ignoring this
particular story because of some
personal bias David and you're a bad
person here's one example I received
like a half a dozen of these in the last
few weeks and the gist is the same for
all of them this is just one example so
someone who on Reddit goes by the name
sinker
posts guys David and Elon what's up with
David totally avoiding the Elon news
he's barely touched on it I know he
drives a Tesla but that can't be why
he's dodging this Insight sorry if it's
been asked so two components okay the
first component is I've been ignoring
the story of Elon Musk buying Twitter
and genuinely behaving like a [ __ ] and
part two is that it's because I drive a
Tesla or I'm an investor in Tesla so
let's take the questions in two parts
first have I been ignoring it no I have
not in November alone we have seven
YouTube videos either directly or
indirectly about Elon Musk and Twitter
one of those is Tucker talking about an
Elon Musk conspiracy theory this
includes a story yesterday on Elon Musk
unbanning Trump from Twitter we've
covered it on the bonus show endless
additional times since the beginning of
Elon Musk looking at buying Twitter
dozens and dozens of Stories the stories
don't do super well
I consider that a signal that my
audience isn't that interested in it but
there has been plenty of coverage that's
number one secondly and this is really
the part that I want to address is the
idea that I'm not covering it or I am
covering it in a particular way because
I drive a Tesla or I'm a Tesla investor
we saw another version of this with
stuff with the israeli-palestinian
conflict I'm not covering it because I'm
Jewish and then it's well I covered it
in a certain way because I'm Jewish and
then I'm covering it a lot because I'm
Jewish okay
first of all this entire Tesla thing is
silly but more importantly
I'm no huge Tesla fan and in fact I
would gladly stop being a Tesla driver
if I could get out of my Tesla lease
without it costing me money so let me
give you the full story and maybe we can
put this to bed I bought Tesla stock in
2015.
that's almost eight years ago as of last
week I've now sold the vast majority of
the stock
I plan to sell all of it I want to wait
until January 1st to sell what's left
because I want to spread out the capital
gains that I'm going to owe and not owe
a whole bunch of taxes all at once now
if by the way the stock is tanking if it
keeps losing value between now and when
I sell in early January I might not even
owe taxes because I'll have you know my
gains will have evaporated that's number
one I bought the stock not because of
being some Elon Musk Fanboy but because
I believed that Tesla as a first mover
into longer range electric vehicles was
going to do well as a company the stock
did do well but I also knew including
from driving the car myself Tesla's big
Advantage is being the first mover on
the charging network and on the on the
Range the build quality of Tesla
vehicles isn't that great it's not that
great and I can tell you as someone who
has a Tesla right now
I've driven in
uh BMW electric vehicles Audi Mercedes
Porsche they are way better cars than
Tesla I've ridden in a friend's Hyundai
ioniq 5. uh okay it's a little bit of a
lower priced car but it's still these
companies have been building cars for in
some cases a hundred years they are way
better built vehicles I believe that the
first mover Advantage for Tesla is
clearly diminishing and as that happens
it's less of an interesting company so
I'm going to be getting out great that
Tesla was a first mover and push things
forward
I think it's prospects in the future are
not nearly as bright now in terms of my
lease and being a Tesla driver I would
bail on it today but I would have to pay
a lease early termination fee it's like
a bunch of payments doesn't matter it
would be forty five hundred dollars if I
want to turn in my lease today I can do
it but it's 4 500 wasting forty five
hundred dollars because I think Elon
Musk is clearly now a knucklehead
doesn't seem super logical if you people
who are angry with me about the car want
to pay for the early termination fee I
will gladly turn in the car
turn in the keys there are no keys and
film myself doing it okay and then we'll
turn it into content and I'll get a
different card the only reason I still
drive a Tesla today is I have a lease
and unless I want to pay I have to keep
the car to the end of the lease lastly
Elon Musk
um I believe Elon Musk has fallen into
the reactionary libertarian black hole
I think it's a very dumb black hole that
many have fallen into I think his
purchase of Twitter is bad for social
media and it's bad for Twitter I also
recognize he's had successful businesses
and people in the past who have bet
against his businesses came out on the
wrong sides of many of those bets I
don't find him super interesting as an
individual that's the full story there's
no hidden agenda I'm not avoiding
talking about Twitter or Elon Musk or
Tesla there's no secret Tesla driver
silence or Allegiance or any of it so
please folks let's drop it we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P here is a furious trumpist
caller who sounds like she really wants
to speak to the manager
um who do you think you are you know you
pompous ass uh calling Mega people
mentally ill you know that's a real
stretch
you know you got to get off this stuff
who Do You Think You Are
nobody
so again listen
uh uh I have never said
all Mega people are mentally ill
but I've interviewed enough of them and
our correspondents have interviewed
enough of them to know
that some of these Maga people are
mentally ill and the manifestation is an
obsession with Trump and Trump
paraphernalia and Trump gear others just
are ignorant about politics others are
selfish and greedy and they identified
that Trump policies would be good for
them you know it's a combination who am
I I'm just like you I you have an
opinion and I have an opinion and we
express the opinions it just might be
that more people are listening to my
opinion than yours but who am I I'm just
a guy that's it we have a great voice of
bonus show for you today has the world
made progress on climate change like all
of the years now of rallies and marches
and Provisions and agreements have we
made what we can call progress on
climate change we will discuss based on
a new report
secondly New Zealand is going to vote on
whether to lower the voting age to 16.
what do we think of it I will tell you
and we will talk about the rising cost
of Thanksgiving and I will again
advocate for ditching the turkey and
doing two or three beautiful chickens
potentially spatchcocked I know I know I
will address that on the bonus show sign
up at joinpakman.com don't miss it
coupon code 24 starts now gets you a
discount